from Instagram postings to snapchat
messages the world is communicating like
never before but that doesn't include
much of America's homeless population
people who've stepped off the grid and
into the shadows for some homeless
people in San Francisco a new service is
using the tools we all take for granted
to repair those broken bonds meg Oliver
has that story in downtown San Francisco
on any given block signs of a supersonic
tech economy share streets with people
who are all but forgotten that they
unlikely have much in common the good
will of a few are bringing them together
in the hope of making miracles
it starts with off-duty tech workers who
volunteer to be digital detectives
databases apps online searches are part
of their arsenal to locate people who
made a difference in a homeless person's
past then they send a message I would
like to see you again if possible could
be a coach it could be a friend a plea
called miracle messages it's the
brainchild of Kevin Adler who's homeless
uncle became part of his life after 30
years of separation we always hear about
the mental health the addiction the
substance abuse that accounts for about
a third of homelessness but a third is
related to economic dislocation so you
know job loss eviction the other third
is related to relational brokenness so
loss of a loved one the death in the
family getting kicked out of home a
divorce a separation and so what we're
doing is we're targeting that aspect of
homelessness you know you have family
and friends you have social supports
let's record a message I miss you all
very much when you were homeless were
you in contact with any of your family
members I was ashamed how lonely were
you bury your pride said you don't want
to you're too proud to let them see me
in the state I was so I stayed away for
almost 13 years before I really
connected back on my mom
Beverly Stephenson and her friend Brian
both no longer homeless are paid miracle
message ambassadors who double as the
advertising department with business
cards in hand and t-shirts that say it
all they put boots on the ground to walk
the streets around Union Square prime
San Francisco real estate where
Beverly's lived for 13 years so what are
you saying to them I just told you no
we're here to help you out to cope with
loss of loved ones family brothers and
sisters uncles cousins did you ever wish
somebody would come by and stop and talk
to you many times I get out I used to
get out and I said I'm doorways crying I
need help
Karen flood of the San Francisco Union
Square Business Improvement District was
willing to help by supporting miracle
messages work they are human beings so
we do need to address you know address
them humanely
do you think people have forgotten that
I think so I think pink the level of
frustration has just gotten really high
in our city so you don't always look at
people you know you look at the problems
maybe that they're leaving behind well
we're really targeting the relational
poverty that oftentimes gets overlooked
by other programs I mean food water
shelter clothing housing we all need
that to be fully human but is that all
we need you know we also need love
belonging sense of social support in the
four years since miracle messages small
staff started searching for lost loved
ones some 200 homeless people have
reconnected with people who are eager to
find them every day now we have two or
three families on average a day reaching
out to us looking for their homeless
relatives I love you both
the average time spent away from each
other is 20 years but for those who do
meet again everyone is somebody someone
is much more than just a slogan on a
t-shirt
meg Oliver CBS News San Francisco Wow
what a what a great idea and he's so
simple that's stunning average time 20
years apart without being with some that
sense of support what really struck a
chord with me is when I did the story in
Minnesota on the veterans homelessness
that's what they create there is that a
support system if you don't have that
family necessarily there's that common
bond of how do we end this problem in
these greater communities you've got to
have that something we have to cut away
each slice at a time because there's so
many slices to that pie amazing program
and it's a growing problem in so many
cities and especially in San Francisco